You were great hosting
"Saturday Night Live."
Congratulations.
That was fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Were you nervous going into it?
-Oh, my gosh.
I was freaking out.
On Monday,
I got there and I was like,
"There's no way
I can get through this week."
-Oh, really?
-And then -- Yeah.
I mean, no one can prepare you
for that, whatever they say.
Just so much going, you know,
going on
and coming at you,
and it's terrifying.
But, you know --
You know, you just have to
make fun of yourself
and don't take it seriously
and just kind of go with it.
-And at the end,
don't you feel like...
-And then on Saturday, I was
begging them to bring me back.
-Yeah.
-I was like,
"Please have me again."
-Yeah.
When you're done, you're like,
"Alright.
Let's do it one more time."
-It's incredible.
It's the best experience ever.
-You mentioned in your monologue
that you're about to
become a U.S. citizen.
-I am.
-So that's exciting.
-Well, I think so.
The guy, after the interview,
he was like,
"Yeah, you're approved.
So make sure
you don't do anything
before the oath ceremony."
I'm like,
"What am I going to do?"
-Yeah. Wow.
-What?!
-You don't know when the
ceremony is? Or it's soon?
-I do. Next month. Yeah.
-Next month. Congratulations.
-Yeah. It's pretty cool.
-You're gonna be a U.S. citizen.
It's a big deal.
-Yeah, it's a big deal.
I love it. Yeah.
It's very special.
-How long have you been
in the U.S.?
-I think about eight years.
-Yeah. Eight years.
-Seven, eight. I don't know.
-And New York City
was the first place you came to?
-I did, yeah. This was --
The first time I ever came
to the U.S. was New York.
And this is where I found my --
my little dog, Elvis.
Yeah.
-No way.
-This is where Elvis --
-Elvis is a New Yorker.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It was meant to be.
-Why did you -- Elvis?
-I was going out and about
in New York,
and I got in the wrong subway,
so I had to go up
to the street again
to get, you know, downtown.
And he was there in the --
in a window, in the glass.
And I was like,
"That's my dog."
So all my girlfriends went back
to Spain with new bags
and, you know,
clothes and new fashion.
And I went back with a dog.
-Yeah.
And why did you name him Elvis?
-Elvis is -- At the time,
I was just listening a lot
to Elvis Presley.
It was what was going on.
It was my ring phone --
like the ringtone.
And it was all about Elvis.
-I love that.
Well, it's been such a year
for you because not only "SNL"
and not only,
of course, citizenship,
but you also were nominated
for an Oscar.
Congratulations for that.
Well-deserved.
-Thank you.
-Well-deserved.
You were so great in "Blonde."
How did it feel?
What were the Oscars --
What did it feel like?
Was it amazing? Was it --
-It was -- It was amazing.
-Yeah.
-It was --
It was also an experience
that you can only, you know --
You have to be there
to know what it feels like.
It was pretty surreal.
-Yeah.
-It was awesome.
-Did you end up
meeting new friends?
Did you sit at a fun table?
-A lot of people.
You meet a lot of people --
all these actors
that you've always been,
you know,
looking up to
and admiring their work.
There was one in particular that
I was very, very happy to meet.
-Yeah, and this is Ke.
Ke Huy Quan.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Who won an Oscar.
-Who won an Oscar.
Who won everything. Yeah.
-How did you meet him at first?
-I met him --
I was at the Governors Ball.
-Yeah.
-And he came to me.
And I was by myself.
And I didn't know who he was,
and he asked me for a selfie.
And then, of course, you know,
if you've seen his Instagram,
he posts selfies
with everybody.
And my boyfriend saw the selfie
and he was like,
"Oh, my God! You met Ke!"
And I'm like, "Yeah.
Who are you talking about?"
He's like,
"He's Data from 'The Goonies'!"
[ Laughter ]
-He is!
-And I'm like, "What?!"
-Yeah, I know,
but I grew up, like --
For some reason in Cuba,
they would play "The Goonies"
all the time on TV.
Like, this was one of my
favorite movies ever growing up,
and I didn't realize that Ke
was the guy from "The Goonies."
-Yeah, he was a kid at the time.
Yeah. Now he's a man.
-This selfie was so horrible.
I'm so serious because
I'm like, "Hm." I don't know.
-You didn't know him.
-I just didn't know.
I didn't get excited.
-But then you saw him again.
-I saw him, and I was like --
I ran to him and I was like,
"I need a selfie with you!"
-Yeah. Exactly. Right.
-Then I was very, very happy.
Of course.
-Well, I have two pictures.
I have two selfies.
Here's the one that he took when
you didn't really recognize him.
[ Laughter ]
And then here's the one
after you went up to him.
You're like, "Oh, yeah! Hey!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about --
Let's talk about your new movie.
"Ghosted."
It's with Chris Evans.
Gosh. He's just fantastic.
He was here last night.
-I saw it.
-You guys are great together.
This is your third movie
you've done together?
-Yeah. Third movie together.
-"Knives Out."
-Yeah, we met in "Knives Out"
and "Gray Man."
-"Gray Man."
-And now "Ghosted."
-Yeah. So you've thrown up
on him in "Knives Out."
You've killed --
You've shot him.
-Yes. I shot him in the butt.
-Yes. And now you --
-Threw up on his face.
And in this one,
I'm trying to --
Well, I kiss him.
I'm nice to him.
-You save him.
-I save him.
-You save his life.
-Even better. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-The idea -- I love it.
It's basically you guys,
two beautiful-looking people,
meet, and they go,
"Oh, let's go on maybe a date."
So they go on a date,
and then you ghost him.
-Well, I'm working.
-Yeah, but he doesn't know that.
He doesn't know.
And so he goes, "Wait."
So he got ghosted by you.
He's like --
But then he realizes that
he forgot that you have his --
-I got his inhaler,
which has one of those.
-He put an Apple Tag on it.
So he can track you.
And he's like, "Wait.
I'm going to find out.
Maybe it will be romantic.
She's in London.
I'll go surprise her
and be like..."
-Don't do that, people.
Don't show up.
-Yeah. It's called stalking.
Don't do that. Yeah.
-Don't do that.
-Don't do that. Yeah.
But he's embarrassed. He's like,
"Alright. I took it too far.
I texted her too much.
That's why she's ghosting me."
Then he finds out
you're a secret agent.
-Yeah.
-You're a spy.
And you are a kick-ass spy.
You're fantastic at it.
-I try. Yeah.
-Yeah. I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Ana de Armas
and Chris Evans
in "Ghosted" on Apple TV+.
Take a look.
-I really ate it up, too,
didn't I?
Especially that sob story
about your coworker that died.
That is low!
-That was actually true.
Her name was Elena.
-And she really died?
-I may have killed her.
-What?!
-She was an enemy agent.
She worked for these guys.
-You said she was a co-worker.
-She was -- in a loose sense.
-See, this is what
I'm talking about.
It's just lies and lies
and more lies.
-It's no lies and more lies.
It's the sub-lie
of the first original lie.
-You're unbelievable.
-Yeah, that's right.
"Ghosted." Ana de Armas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last time you were here,
you were talking about how one
of your favorite ice creams
is my ice cream,
which is The Tonight Dough.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so I loved that so much.
And that's why I wanted
to celebrate your big year
by maybe having
a spoonful together.
-Listen. If you give me ice
cream every time I come here...
-But wait.
I'm gonna do one better.
Because you said, actually,
if you wanted to change
the flavor, we were like,
"What would you do?"
You go,
"Maybe I'd add a little..."
-Condensed milk.
Well, our friends at
Ben & Jerry's heard this
and wanted to send you
a message. Take a look.
-Hi, Ana. I'm Ben.
-I'm Jerry.
-We were so excited to hear
that Ben & Jerry's
The Tonight Dough
is your favorite ice cream.
-We love that you're a fan
and came up
with something in our kitchen
for a special one-day-only,
one-time-only surprise.
-Jimmy, can you show Ana
what we come up with?
-Since it was
a dream of yours...
-You're kidding.
-...to have your own flavor,
we like to make dreams
come true.
Here's your special
one-time-only
Ana de ArMAS Leche.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-Come on! I'm not kidding!
You got to try it.
It's condensed milk.
It's condensed milk
in the ice cream.
Here's the recipe
on how to make it.
That's your condensed milk
right in the middle there.
Oh, my God.
-You can see it.
Yeah. There you go.
-This is too much.
-We wanted our studio audience
to join in
on the celebration, too,
so everyone in the audience
is going home with
some Ben & Jerry's tonight
and the directions
to make it are posted.
Come on! Ben & Jerry!
Ana de Armas!
Come on, everybody!
Now, this is like
Pictionary with a twist, okay?
Now, I'm going to grab a clue
that I have to draw
on your back, okay?
I'll put a piece
of paper on your back.
And while I'm drawing,
you try to re-create
what I'm drawing
on that easel over there,
while you're
guessing what I'm drawing.
-Okay.
-Okay? Are you ready for this?
-Mm-hmm.
-Let's try Round 1.
Audience, clue?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Wow.
I like that.
Alright.
Okay. I think we can do this.
Alright, turn around.
I will put -- I will put this --
-Should I get this one?
Oh, I have the big one here.
-Yeah, you'll have
the good marker there.
Okay. Ready?
-Oh, my God.
-Alright, are you ready, bud?
I think this is
gonna be -- Okay.
Ready? Here we go.
-Wait. Slow, slow, slow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
I haven't started yet.
♪♪
-Oh.
-Yes.
How much time?
-That?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. What do you think?
What's your guess?
-Is it a -- It's a --
I don't know -- a --
[ Buzzer ]
-Yes. What does that look like?
That's fantastic.
Better than what I drew.
This -- yours is better
than what I drew.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what I drew.
[ Dinging ]
Lightning bolt.
-Lightning bolt.
♪♪
-Oh, you would have got that.
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-It's thunder and
lightning bolt, right?
That was good.
-Yeah.
That's good.
Alright, now -- Alright.
-Okay.
-Let's try again.
Tariq, what are you laughing at?
-Because she -- How is hers
better than the one --
-It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter. Whatever.
It was the first round.
Okay, what clue should she pick?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Six. Six?
-Alright, I'm not gonna look.
-Oh.
-I'm not looking, not looking.
No cheating, no cheating.
I'm not looking.
-I like it.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Okay.
-Okay.
-We got this?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Okay.
♪♪
Wait. What? Do it again?
Sorry.
-Sorry, sorry.
-Sorry. Do it again.
Wow.
-How -- [ Laughs ]
How are you feeling that?
-I have --
I'm feeling fantastic.
I don't know
what I'm feeling right now.
Uh...
I don't know.
[ Buzzer ]
Ooh, wow!
-Wait! I'm not done.
-Oh, well,
I think one of us is --
I think -- Wait.
Do it one more time.
Yes.
I think there's a heart
on there.
I don't know what it is.
I'm going to say a clock?
A clock. Was I remotely close?
I got lost.
Oh, it was a butterfly.
A much nicer thing.
I'm sorry.
I should have gotten that.
-You're covering your --
-Mine was terrible.
[ Air horn blows ]
Ooh!
You know what that sound means.
It means it's time
for the final round.
Okay, we're going to
shake things up here.
Quest, you want to give me
a hand over here?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, for this round,
we're playing
"Triple Backtionary."
Ana, you will draw on my back
and I will draw on Quest's back
and then he will draw
on his easel.
If he guesses what we're
trying to draw, we all win.
-It'll be a miracle.
-Wait. Yeah.
-It will be a miracle.
Exactly right.
-Okay.
-Ana, pick a clue.
What do you guys think?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-10?
Okay.
-Okay, that's you.
No, you got that -- Oh.
-Okay.
-Alright.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Whoa. Okay. Wait.
-They said, "Aww."
-Yeah, I know.
It must be like
a puppy or something.
[ Chuckling ]
Okay.
-Alright.
Ana, I'm trusting you on this.
Yep.
-I mean, you can't
get this wrong.
-Oh.
♪♪
-Are we done?
-You got to do it...
Wait. Are you doing it?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-Wait. Do it again!
Do it again! Do it again!
-I'm done.
-No, no. -- You --
Quest, no.
Quest, what are you doing?
-I'm doing what you're doing?
[ Buzzer ]
-What the heck
are you drawing, dude?
What are you drawing?
-No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Do it again. Do it again.
-One more time. One more time.
Do it again.
-I mean, mine is
pretty bad, too.
-Go.
-Okay.
♪♪
Oh.
Oh. Oh.
Oh, wait, wait.
Is it that?
-Yes.
-Well, I do more -- Yeah, mine
is different, but, yes,
that's the idea.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
♪♪
-It was sun.
-Oh!
-Sun!
-Yes.
-I thought you were
doing a flower.
-Okay.
-That's not a good sun.
-"Questlove
has a new book out now."
There you go right there.
So he's the winner,
it's Questlove.
Ana's new movie --
Ana de Armas --
"Ghosted," premieres on
Apple TV+ this Friday.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."